[Music]
Angela White what what how did this
happen
I met you at the premiere of the roast
and it all went crazy from there why do
I feel like as soon as we met we were
friends I don't know but something about
the way you touched me which sounds
I I need to watch it apparently yeah you
you grabbed me and I was like wow like
in my head I was like wow she's really
touching me but I mean
no I
okay so Angela White is coming forward
with an allegation no no I'd rather not
be here for this I feel like this is
supposed to be between you and your
lawyer
no you you grabbed me in a way I was
impressed because a lot of people don't
really touch each other in La like it's
very like there's no meaning behind your
actress the producer will touch you as
much as you want
um at the Christmas party uh and as much
as you don't want frankly but we hadn't
met I knew you were coming I knew of you
a little bit it's not that I don't know
you really well
um because I know how famous you are I
had you know Alex from only fans had
sent me you know a list of who was
coming and I was like oh God and I
I I didn't totally know but I could feel
that you were someone does that make
sense well like I could feel you have
Star Energy
thank you and your yeah and your eyes I
are wild and we connected and it was a
very um chaotic situation and I went up
to like hug you or something yeah and
I'm so grateful that you came oh I was
so happy to be there I had so much fun
it was great I just like I can only
really I am so at ease around sex
workers because it's a comedians same
same yeah you know we're giving our uh
you know it's like I don't use it very
vulnerable yeah like yeah giving your
body to people for their you know enjoy
we give our emotions and insecurities
and Etc so it's it always just feels
very safe to me yeah
yeah I hope because we were on a podcast
together recently and you were like you
hugged me really hard at that party and
I was like is she gonna sue me no I am
not going to sue you I would like you to
do it again
no I you you're interested if I don't do
it again yeah like if you don't keep
hugging me like that it's over you you
we were on the red carpet or the blue
carpet because it was for only fans yeah
and you you grabbed me and you looked
into my eyes and I was like wow she's
real
yeah
and we hugged yeah
enveloped yeah
and you haven't you have such a warmth
to you and I get and I don't know why
that's surprising I think in some way
I'm very intimidated by you uh and what
you do because I admire it so much and I
I'm scared of it you know I think people
tend to think
stand-up comedy is the scariest thing
the hardest thing the most uh
embarrassing thing or the most
um the thing that requires the most
amount of Courage but I look at sex work
and I go like that see that I am you
know that's where I get well I think we
do the thing we both do the things that
people find the scariest it's public
speaking and being naked in front of
people yep so
that's
yeah has this been like what and I'm
gonna just start from the beginning okay
at what point in your life were you did
you become sexual did it become
comfortable like how when was this this
is my life this is my dream this is my
future 14. 14 14 is kind of like
that was when everything started
happening that's when I developed my
breaths that's when I was super sexual
Express this big off the Jump it pretty
much not quite this big
um at 14 I was a double D so and then
they just slowly grew after that but it
felt like overnight like I was 13 flat
chested 14 double d tits I had a girl in
my school that had she was very very
short shorter than you and she had such
big boobs it was like a problem like she
had back problems yeah Kate Upton's a
good friend of mine she you know she had
trouble breastfeeding like she's like
big boobs are kind of a traumatic
Chelsea Lynn who's only fans trailer
trashed Tammy when she said she couldn't
play sports because they would hit her
they'd hit her in the face I'm like this
feels like a fucked up karmic punishment
um and were they was it when they what
was your experience when they started
coming in because I think very few
people are like oh you have big boobs I
feel so bad for you but it must be kind
of confusing it is I mean they're a
blessing and a curse I mean I for me
they're mainly a blessing but um I did
get that time okay so before you were
like these are gonna make me an iconic
millionaire
so before that I mean at 13 all my other
friends had developed so I was flat
chested so I would cry myself to sleep
because I didn't have tits and my mom
would always say don't worry you're
going to get tits and you're going to
catch up and you're going to overtake
everyone which I didn't believe her at
the time yes everyone in my family both
my grandmothers have big tits so it's
like both sides of the family big
titties all my cousins my sisters
everyone has big tits but at 13 not
having like I had nothing and my friends
had tits even if they were BLC cups I'm
like I'm a horny woman that wants to
express and explore myself and I have no
tits and I felt like tits were the
ticket what do you mean you're at 13
were you masturbating at that time yes
that I was trying to think when you came
on I was like when did I masturbate
first like I does any do people remember
like I just wrapped my head around my
losing my virginity thing story like
remembering but I don't remember when I
figured that out
see I was doing like sexual
self-pleasuring things before I knew
what masturbation was because I think
about what I did with my friends when we
were kids and like humping like the
dolls and things like that which is
basically masturbation you know so so
just so you're with Australia yeah
everyone this is where they sent the
criminals they sent the criminals to an
island to go hump dolls
I don't think that's why but that is
what ended up happening
[Laughter]
so casually yeah I I don't I didn't do
hump dolls with your friends yeah with
my friends yeah we did it together like
we would do these little ceremonies
where we would get married to the soft
toys and then we would hump them because
we'd have to consummate the marriage so
we would hump we would be in bed
together side by side humping the dolls
yeah and we would you know make our
Barbies have sex and stuff I mean that
wasn't masturbation but we were yeah
exploring sex and sexual ideas was there
do you remember seeing images in movies
or magazines that like led to it or no
nothing led to it I I do remember seeing
like naked people in movies was so
exciting I remember like the full
frontal nudity in Life of Brian like
that was just so exciting my name was
household like my you know I had family
members that cheated and stuff and I
would go to the mistress's home and like
see stuff oh wow yeah I remember like
I've there was the household was there
were women in the house naked coming in
coming out and I kind of I think and I
can't I can't really delineate whether
it was like oh this is sexual I'm into
sex or it's like oh this is what gets my
dad's attention so I should do that uh
look like that or exactly you know what
I mean like it was kind of like at a
very early age at an early age I was
just so fascinated with naked bodies and
sex even if it wasn't like a sexual
thing bodies are just so ridiculous and
it's sweet that we are not allowed to
see them how can you see it let a kid
love a moon bounce but not jump on
titties
same same yeah soft bouncy things yeah
this episode is brought to you by Kerry
Uma the cool sustainable sneaker company
made for life on and off the board
warmer days are ahead and we all need
that staple shoe to carry us through
summer and Beyond when it comes to days
spending the sunshine and on your feet
carry almost got you covered with
effortless style unmatched comfort and
premium quality worn by celebrities like
Ashton Kutcher and me that's not on the
prompter why didn't they include me in
that I wonder I feel like when Ashton
Kutcher does his reads they're like
celebrities like Whitney Cummings
praised by Publications like Vogue and
GQ these are a cult fave Oka is carry
uma's new school take on Timeless
sneaker style it's designed for everyday
wear and with breathable or breathing
what's that like it's in Shades like
green off-white and Rose is the perfect
pair to prep for summer they sure to
have the perfect color for you we've
loved the lace-up Ocha now carrying
recently launched canvas slip-ons made
with organic cotton and natural rubber
outsole this easy to wear style provides
a Timeless look with Incredible comfort
and ease it's everything you love about
Oka now without the laces carry um is
always keeping it fresh with epic
collaborations with Brands like deuce
Avatar and Pantone there's something to
love for everyone and sure to be shoes
you will never get bored of carayuma is
a b Corp certified and has dedicated
reforestation program based in the
Brazilian Rainforest they're good people
too what their co-founders David and
Fernando both grew up there so this
project is especially close to home for
every sneaker uh
for every pair of sneakers sold carry
Yuma plants two trees and they've
already planted over 2 million trees to
date that is so freaking cool and hot
carry Uma ships all their sneakers free
and fast in the USA and offers worldwide
shipping in 60 day free returns they
deliver right to your front door using
single box recycled packaging and for a
limited time good for you listeners can
get an exclusive 15 off your pair of
carium sneakers go to carry Yuma
c-a-r-i-u-m-a.com Whitney to get 15 off
that's carry Uma
c-a-r-i-u-m-a.com slash Whitney for 15
off only for a limited time I I was that
weird kid at school in the back of the
library reading all the sex books like
there's a book called where did we come
from which had all the cartoon
illustrations of naked people in
reproduction and reproductive organs and
that was fascinating to me and I was you
know I knew I wasn't supposed to like
look at it every single day so I'd
always go to the back of the library to
like stare at these cartoon images
so I've always been fascinated by sex
and sexuality
and naked bodies but was there a
religion in your house at all because I
think maybe the the in marigolds before
there's just such a religious shame like
a fabric of shame that underpins
everything that I feel like
it was so I was brought up Christian but
it wasn't like a super strict religious
household
um my mum was really open with me about
sex and masturbation
um she's a photographer cool yeah so it
makes sense that I ended up on the other
side of the screen
um but yeah she she was really open with
me like she gave me a copy of um the
share the the height report do you know
this book sheer height wrote this book
in the 70s
um and it basically surveyed women on
their sexual experiences and on
masturbation and how they masturbated
because she wanted me to she actually
asked me like do you know how to
masturbate are you coming at what age I
can't remember what age I want to say it
was around 14 it was around that age and
so she gave me this book and in the book
women detail the ways to you by Sherry
hate yeah wow so she so in that blue
card yeah it's a great it's a classic
text and um women detail the ways that
they actually masturbate and so it was
you know from reading that book that I
got a mirror and looked down at my vulva
and figured out like where's the
clitoris and learn how to master the
first time you put the mirror up it's a
real it's yeah it's it's
it was good to have have to have studied
so many illustrations
I knew kind of what it was supposed to
look like so it wasn't so yeah yeah
so I was messed up why does this look
like my laundry basket
um
did she was she very involved when you
were like going through puberty and
having your period and stuff yeah so
when I um so she knew at the like when I
had a boyfriend she knew that this was
probably going to be the one that I lost
my virginity to so even before like that
happened she was like you know if you
want to have sex like let's talk I'll
give you some condoms all that kind of
stuff and then when I lost my virginity
she gave me like a present like a losing
your virginity present yeah she bought
me some lingerie oh yeah my mom was my
mom was great Turned Down For What yeah
she's great damn and was she married yes
what's his deal
um I mean what do you mean what's he
like deal with like he's it's just he's
just what's his what's up with him
what's up Dad I guess I'm just like I
don't know I don't even know how to talk
about dads I mean I didn't I didn't have
the same I did I didn't have the same
relationship with my dad like my me and
my dad weren't open about sex
yeah you're about to get slammed yeah
Mommy's Mommy's girl totally yeah I
think there's this sort of um
I don't want to say stereotype myth
whatever that like if you like sex a lot
you your dad must have failed or
something and I think I always try to
challenge that yes you know uh I think
most people like sex yeah yeah
regardless of what you know what's up
with Dad yeah yeah yeah yeah and so
you're in Australia and then you you
lose your virginity at what point are
you like when you lost your like did you
enjoy it when do you start enjoying sex
because I think for most people sex is
not this is not the experience yeah you
know so I'm just so curious if you know
I I maybe had the way that you had a
positive relationship with comedy I'm
sorry
the way that you had a positive
relationship with
um sex I developed a positive
relationship with comedy earlier yeah
with my it's like when traumatic things
would happen or bad things would happen
like jokes would cut the tension and
everyone would laugh and I was like okay
this is the thing this is what's you
know so it's like obviously
that's where the pavlovian sort of like
desire to keep doing that you know came
from
um but I'm curious like because most
people I think losing your virginity is
kind of like usually not a great that's
not great yeah if I is I'm like yeah it
wasn't like I was having like multiple
orgasms and you know it was the best sex
of my life nothing's it was the peak you
know like you know and then it kind of
taints it and then you're so and because
maybe America is a little bit different
because it's a lot of like furtive you
know religious shame you're dry humping
in closets and getting your braces stuck
on someone's cock ring it was just like
it's you don't really have good sex so
you're like 30 in America
um
so there was sort of a relief after I
lost my virginity because there was so
much like
The Virginity thing like there's so much
tied to that like it's so important you
know and a lot and leading up to losing
my virginity I'd done basically
everything else like I was just sucking
dick all the time because I was like I
could I loved sucking dick it was so
much fun for me because I was like this
is a way for me to be sexual but I can
still protect my precious virginity yeah
you know I can suck anyone's dick that
doesn't have to be special but popping
the Cherry that has to be with someone I
love and it has to be beautiful and
wonderful and something that I'll
remember forever so once I once I lost
it I felt relief because I'm like oh no
I can fuck anyone I want because like I
made the first time special so now it
doesn't matter I enjoy sex for a myriad
of ways it's not just like the pleasure
I feel in being touched in my body and
the orgasm and things like that like I
enjoy connecting I enjoy being naked
with someone I enjoy expressing and
exploring I like I just loved exploring
things even if I didn't like it because
I had especially at that age I there
were so many things that I had tried so
I'm like yeah what's it like to stick a
finger in my butt what's it like to you
know whatever it is like there were so
many things I hadn't done so it was a
really exciting time in my life and now
I still like when I'm having sex with
someone there's so many different ways
that I can connect with someone and it's
always a new experience
so I'm always just curious like because
you're so like like
you're such a ray of light there's just
an orb of like positivity and I just
feel like when someone something's going
well for someone someone discovers
something
and I think for a lot of people's sex
like you didn't have it tainted and
shamed it doesn't seem like before you
did it and then after you did it it
doesn't seem like there was a lot of
slut shamey whatever so oh there was
yeah because I'm like how have you not
gone dark you just I'm just trying to
find the part in this trajectory because
like
you know I'm you know I think most women
would probably be like you uh point of
view wise with sex and I I wish they
could be but I think so many women
either got embarrassed or ashamed
whether it's hate their bodies or got
slut shamed or yeah bad sex or whatever
it is oh yeah I got slut shamed like
crazy in high school that's what ended
up leading me into porn so basically I
turned 14 I get rid of my virginity and
I'm like oh it's on now I can fuck
everyone so I was fucking guys I was
fucking girls I was slut shamed for
every way that I expressed my fucking
girls was that like I just want to learn
about it or like I'm attracted both both
I wanted to I wanted to try everything I
was attracted to women but that at that
time that wasn't cool it wasn't cool to
kiss girls so that was probably the
thing that I was shamed for the most was
having a girlfriend in high school what
yeah that was like not and I guess at
the school I was at it was just like
there was so much
in high school like like dating full-on
and I actually was made to apologize at
school assembly for kissing my girl in
the quadrangle like like heterosexual
couples could kiss all they wanted but
because I kissed my girlfriend in the
quadrangle that was considered making a
scene and we were made to apologize to
the school like I went through a lot of
trauma in high school for myself I
Angela Wade I'm sorry for giving all the
teachers erections
on the quad earlier yeah that was my bad
yeah fucked up you had I had to
apologize I went through some fucked up
stuff in high school for because of my
sexuality and the other thing okay so
high school which is by the way the fact
that I look back now and I'm like the
high school prom homecoming Sadie
Hawkins these the why are these you guys
are just like encouraging the students
to stress out obsess over who they're
going to invite and eventually fuck at
the end of May like all like that is so
spooky to me the fact that they have any
judgments when it's just kind of like a
weird like breeding program not as big
of a deal in Australia the whole prom
thing oh really yeah in America it's it
really breaks people yeah you're you and
I are best friends and we're in high
school and then the quarterback asks you
to prom and then all of a sudden we're
not friends anymore and then it's like
and then you go to the prom and all the
teachers are there watching us dance and
kind of dry hump and like sort of graze
boners to Hozier Take Me To Church
whatever is happening and then you know
they're gonna have sex that it's just
like why are the teachers here oh so are
you guys like when you have sex why are
you here for the foreplay like what is
this like it's just yeah
okay it's just like it's I just find it
very toxic and it's taken this long for
me to look back and go like that's
bizarre like just that we encourage
anyway so that's not a big thing in
Australia but because you had a
girlfriend
um by the time prom came around I had a
boyfriend but if I hadn't had a
boyfriend I probably wouldn't have even
gone what happened with the girl
um just I can't even remember why we
broke up but just didn't work out it
wasn't like it was we were dating but it
wasn't like serious nothing is really
serious in high school yeah but I mean
but to do that in high school is a big
swing
what's the big deal because what but if
you because like I am dating a girl now
you know and and someone else or
whatever so it's like oh good she's
Whitney she's wacky she has blue hair
she dates girl you know it's like it
kind of works but like that's a big
swing like for 14 15.
to be fully dating a girl at school
because people are going you're a
lesbian well yeah that's exactly
lesbian and so the slang at at least in
at my school for lesbian was lemon so we
had lemons thrown at us like it was like
actual physical bullying I got punched
in the face
yeah like it was like really hardcore
what I went through in high school
imagine being a guy in high school
thinking he has a shot with you and then
finding out he doesn't
well I I was still fucking guys we
fucked guys together too like it wasn't
like they didn't have a chance you need
to have a shirt that's like don't worry
you're you're welcome here
you were punched in the face yeah once
only once thankfully yeah I mean it was
kind of like I have a boy or girl a girl
so I'll tell you this what a hand I I
was always teased for being a lesbian
and this one girl just kept on like
harassing me about it and she just came
up to me she never like had fully
explained why she was bullying me but
she came up to me she's like so what are
you are you a fucking lesbian and I said
why are you interested and I got smacked
yeah and turns out she was a lesbian
actually a couple years later a couple
of years later there's other ways to
touch me okay you don't have to punch me
to touch my face like fuck you yeah yeah
oh honey do you feel like Looking Back
Now with that not to like for like just
to you know make excuses but do you feel
like that was internalized homophobia
because she was yeah jealous yeah it
definitely I mean she obviously felt
uncomfortable about the fact that I was
expressing myself in a way that she
wanted to or didn't know she wanted to
just felt she just felt uncomfortable
about that do you think she'd every time
she comes she thinks about hitting you
in the face in high school I hope she
feels bad about that I feel like
whoever she's married to definitely
thinks about that every night every time
they fight the thing that surprised me
the most about being punched in the face
is how little it hurt like the
adrenaline it's like stunning yeah like
you have so much adrenaline Comfort like
you don't even feel the pain I just was
shaking with so much adrenaline yeah
when you really get injured it's same I
had um uh when my ear was bitten off by
a dog I felt nothing like my ear was
like hanging down felt nothing looked in
the mirror got to in as soon as I was
like
cared for as soon as I got to the
hospital they started like doing stuff
then I was like it's like your brain
knows you know like something they sense
dopamine to the area or oxytocin
whatever it is um I think it's um
phenylethylamine actually
um to uh keep you feeling good so that
you'll save yourself yeah you know what
I mean like uh the girl that got her arm
bitten off by shark Britney someone
Anthony Hamilton Bethany Hamilton
she uh she said that she heard the sound
but it felt like almost orgasmic when
the shark bit her arm off like it sends
so much feel-good chemicals to the area
so that you'll fight for your life and
not give up wow I wonder if she thinks
about that when she orgasms
laughs
and she probably uses her nub I mean how
does she even masturbate what a bummer
she has another hand or what happened
well yeah was I don't know if she's left
or right yeah I mean she must her she
has a nub now okay
imagine if that is the best orgasm
you've ever had in your life and it
never pays that's a big one the idea of
like oh sexo will never be as good as
the shot bite sex with is great babe but
getting bit by getting my arm bitten off
that was that that's my kink
have you encountered any
extreme Kinks and do you have any intel
for me on the king front of where where
they come from
I'm pretty fascinated um
with no judgments no no no no no I
actually I mean I get a lot of
interesting requests on only fans
um I wouldn't say they're extreme
they're just like very creative
um there's like the the volking so their
Kink is making you go
huh I gotta go to I gotta go to I gotta
go to Michael's
there's a there's a lot of like yeah
like I have to you know they want me to
cover myself in cake or something or oh
yeah
um all the the eating ones where you eat
them well they're shrinking no no like
you eat so um I have a lot of guys who
like shrinking fetishes so I used to do
them a lot on webcams so I would like
make a special lemonade that would
actually have a secret potion in there
they wouldn't know that and then they'd
drink it and they'll be like oh my God
what's happening and start to shrink and
so I take the webcam and slowly put the
webcam down on the floor as I laugh
maniacally
um and then
I would play with them as but it
wouldn't always be sexual like sometimes
they just want you to put them in your
pocket or put them in between your
cleavage and just carry them around that
is that first of all that is darling
it's cute right that is precious
so Kinks Kinks I want to send you this
one that I did recently actually because
I think it's still on my phone
hang on let me find this for you waiting
I what is what I would like to I'm gonna
call
Shark Tank I would what service would
allow me how much money would it cost to
just go on your phone for a minute just
through your just through your photos
third videos
I'm gonna add drop this to you hopefully
it's the right one why is my boobs
please I hope you can send into things
by opening this message
yeah okay so that's what a recent one
that I did a little custom for the vore
I am so hungry and you look like such an
incredibly delicious little snack
I hope you don't mind if um
I get straight to it I think you're
gonna digest pretty quickly because I've
been hungry for a while in fact I'm
salivating just looking at you I might
just swallow you home
so um here we go
[Music]
this is literally so many men oh my gosh
Jay you are delicious to be eaten
to be eaten
like little be shrunk and then eaten
I'm gonna call it Army Hammer and figure
out how to eat people man that's where
the money is like what do you think that
is they want to be inside you
in a different way I never ask why
because I don't want I don't want anyone
to ever get in their head about their
father I don't know why yeah I just am
fascinated I'm fascinated too but I just
I just never I'm like you know what if
they wanted to tell me they'd tell me
maybe they don't even know why maybe
they don't even want to know why right
so I just I'm like all right doesn't
matter like but I think there's because
it's not about you know for me whenever
there's something going on with me
that's a compulsion or an obsession I'm
like oh let me figure out what this is
so I can change it or fix it or heal it
or but um but with Kinks like my kings
are always pretty uh helpful information
you know what I mean like mine are like
I so embarrassing I'll do it let's go
like things you fantasize about when
you're masturbating or having sex
whatever
very big into like now
workers at my house not the ones I
currently have but workers that are just
killing it at my house
politely asking to come in the house
should I take my shoes off
and I'm like no
and then they just fuck me and go back
to doing great work that's hot agree
yeah but like in my brain I'm like oh I
really just want competent workers I'm
turned on like because I've had
incompetent
criminals doing work on my house like I
it's in good information yeah you know
what I'm saying I'm like I need to make
a change with my construction crew yeah
I I understand yeah it makes sense I
think a lot of my fantasies now revolve
around me doing less
so because well because in porn I'm so
active I'm basically doing cardio I'm On
Top I'm writing I'm you know getting
fucked upside down I do so much so I
just want to get tied up now I just want
to get tied up how do I how do I become
a bottom yeah how do I be fucked like
how does someone fuck me and I do less
of a comedian doing crowd work we're
like What are you can you do this for me
it's like can you where are you from
like that's same same I've done a lot of
work up here tonight I'm in the same
I've just turned 40 and I'm like what do
you do sir
uh but so when it comes to getting into
when did you decide okay this is
something I want to do for a living okay
so that's going back to all the bullying
and the slut shaming that I experienced
in high school so pornography was the
first place I saw women being celebrated
for fucking a bunch of people I mean you
know it's been it's it's Hedy Lamarr is
someone I'm obsessed with she was a
um uh what was the year let me find
Hedy Lamarr who has now been linked to
uh uh being fundamentally uh I don't
want to say she invented Wi-Fi but
fundamentally involved in the the
invention of Wi-Fi
um she was an actress who was Austrian
and she did a movie called ecstasy in
1933 and it showed her having an orgasm
on camera and she was so publicly shamed
and disgraced that she moved to America
became very famous in America
I don't think anyone wouldn't even know
I don't think the people running
Hollywood wanted anyone to know that was
even on the menu
[Music]
orgasms just don't that's not even a
that's a myth that's really fucked up so
could men orgasm always yeah wow yeah
yeah
that's really why misogynistic yeah yeah
wild so so I never saw sex being
pleasurable to women it was always just
like marriage marriage marriage
whichever Disney movie every rom-com you
know it was all about saving yourself
for marriage it was never like
enjoying sex well that's why porn was so
incredible for me it was like this
Progressive space where I was like oh
wow women are allowed to have fun be
naked fuck men fuck women and they're
celebrated for that rather than
criticized for it so I was like at 14 I
was like that is what I want to do and
what was it do you remember the first
porn you saw I don't okay so I saw a
couple different things
um I don't remember the name of the
movie but I saw some really weird movie
with my with my my soon-to-be boyfriend
and his friend
um where these male performers were
wearing lamps they were naked and they
were wearing lamp shades over their
heads I mean yeah and they end up
getting their dick sucked and fucking
was very odd I don't know what movie
that was and then the the thing still
never found it to this day but we still
have a thing for lampshades no
um but the the thing I remember the most
was I had this Penthouse letters and
there was this blonde woman laying there
covered in lace and pearls and she had
this huge smile on her face and she was
looking directly down the lens just like
staring into your soul with this big
smile on her face and I was like fuck
yes I'm gonna be happy in porn like this
is where I can be myself this is where I
can express myself this is where I can
be me and everyone's gonna love me for
it I can express and explore sex in a
safe place with like-minded peers so
yeah 14 I was like I'm gonna be in porn
that is in Wild that I spent the next
four years researching it figuring out
what companies could be safe to work
with because obviously there were still
a lot of myths surrounding the industry
about it just like
being a place where you know all the
women are pimped out and Drug abused and
what so I I did my research like I was
really serious about figuring out how I
could get it you approached it as a
business I did approach it as a business
did you research any porn stars that
came before you that's actually one of
the reasons I ended up working so the
first company that I worked with was the
score group and they were flying in
models so they're based in Miami Florida
but they were flying in models from
around the world and I was like reading
this is at the time it was magazines
they had DVDs and stuff too but it was
like magazines were the easiest things
for me to get my hands on
and they kept coming back these models I
was like they'd fly them into Florida
they'd fly them into the Bahamas or
they'd fly them into Europe and I was
like oh here they are in in Prague and
then like a year later there in the UK
I'm like well these models wouldn't keep
flying and shooting with this company if
they were treating them poorly
that was that was I mean
that was all the research that I could
that I had and I was like I went into it
with them as much now there's so much I
was right okay yeah I was like I was
right trust me I'm like that could have
gone either way because I'm like you
moved to LA and you're like well that's
Harvey Weinstein guy all these people
wouldn't work with them if he was really
great
seems like they just keep winning Oscars
well this was this was with the
knowledge that I could Garner as a 14
year old now like yeah that you can
listen to a bunch of podcasts where porn
stars talk about their experience at the
time that was the best information that
I could Garner at the time and
thankfully
I was right did you tell your mom about
your plan yeah when she said well she
was worried yeah
I was not as worried as my mom when I
told her I was gonna do comedy
oh
can I tell you you know I it is it is
just it's good look like stand-up comedy
sex work we go hand in hand in so many
ways sorry if that was a weird double
entender but
um uh like comedy in America I mean
comedy started in America essentially um
stand-up comedy there was the Court
Jester that but the court Jester's job
and
Europe was to you know joke around with
the King and make jokes about the king
to make sure the power hadn't corrupted
him you know or uh created some kind of
like ego maniacal brain disease so joke
with the King and if the king didn't
laugh people had to go like oh we're
worried you know or the Jester's job is
to deliver bad news in a silly way and
you know keep things light and the
um courts but um stand-up comedy
it was very much like hip-hop invented
in America and came up in strip clubs
you know and we started this together
Vaudeville May West you know Moms Mabley
Etc and uh and it's just so funny
because it's like I go there's this um
strip club in L.A called crazy girls we
went to an after the Burt roast I wasn't
I didn't get to go so I had to work the
next day so I was like I got it I
figured yeah I just love it because it's
like it's more like bikini bar like
they're it's not even topless I don't
think um they have pasties and stuff but
uh but when I go quite a lot and when I
go uh they're always like how you doing
like they look down on us they're like
we we exploit our bodies for money you
guys exploit like your depression like
they're like how are you like so it's
like you know so so anyway so it just
feels like so Kismet it makes so much
sense this alliance with only fans and
comedy that has started to build
manscaped ladies June is just around the
corner and my guess is that you haven't
purchased a Father's Day gift am I right
well
look no further than the sponsors of
today's show because our friends at
manscaped are sorry I was gonna make a
joke about my dead dad and I didn't so
if you're like me and you don't have a
dad to buy something for uh Father's Day
I mean honestly you know what you
actually could use this incredible razor
to go I could groom around his grave
site
like the grass and stuff and the weeds
anyway you need to gift your dad so that
he could upgrade his grooming game from
face to waste their brand new beard
hedger exactly Pro kit is the total
package dedicated to making sure all
fathers go from dad to Daddy this year
have him join the 8 million men
worldwide who trust manscape to get 20
off plus free shipping with the code
Whitney at manscape.com mama's gonna
like this one let's start with the
ultimate Father's Day MVP the beard
hedger Pro kit inside this package look
at all the stuff you're gonna find their
signature beard hedger trimmer that's
this one Boop beard shampoo and
conditioner here we go the beard bomb I
have it all right here which by the way
you know that I started using
obsessively the manscape shower gel
because it's like addictively delicious
uh also the beard oil which is right
here which I do sometimes put on my face
and the ends of my hair I think I'm
trans by the way maybe I'm trans two
free gifts with their signature my God
it smells so good beard comb and
scissors with 20 hair cutting lengths
and a singular guard he'll be able to
craft his look like never before without
a mess in drawers and if he doesn't have
a beard he needs to try their
performance package 4.0 this beautiful
bundle is absolutely daddy material it
includes the brand new weed whacker 2.0
ear and nose hair trimmer that thing is
a game changer the crop preserver ball
deodorant crop reviver toner because why
do all balls look like they're a hundred
years old performance boxer briefs and a
travel bag to hold all of his goodies
the lawnmower 4.0 is a game changer for
trimming in his sensitive areas we all
know dads love their comfort if his
grooming routine is already dialed make
sure to hook him up with manscapes
boxers 2.0 these are without a doubt the
best boxers for men of all ages get 20
off plus free shipping with the code
Whitney at manscape.com that's 20 off
with free shipping at manscaped.com and
use the code Whitney it makes this
Father's Day say one he will not forget
with manscaped I hope I forget it
because my dad's dead but yeah I do
think it's interesting because I think
comedians you know come from a lot of
disapproval but I feel like you you have
to come from in order to do what you do
you have to come from a lot of approval
and and comfort or
um in terms of like well maybe in within
yourself at least to start when you
started you it seems like you had a lot
of support and structure and you know uh
safety I'm that's not so I'm very
privileged and that my family is very
accepting of what I do and like it was a
journey it wasn't like they were just
like super excited for me from the
beginning
um but there are a lot of performers
that don't have that that do get
ostracized from their family because
there's a lot of jobs where it's like
we'll accept it if you're the best but
in that in that beginning period where
you're making like you know
50 bucks a week that's what you know
what I mean it's like did you was there
a time when it was like just wait till I
can buy you pay your rent and then
you'll be supportive
um thankfully they were supportive
before the money came in but it took so
in the beginning
um so I when I got into the industry I
mean I wanted to get in at 14 obviously
I had to wait till I was 18 I had all
those four years to like plan everything
and get in and when I turned 18 I was
still in high school so it was like a
big deal that I was like well I'm gonna
I mean I still I stayed in school but I
left for two weeks to shoot porn and
then came back and I told my mom I just
turned 18 and I could have told her in a
way that was a lot softer but I was like
just so punk rock I just was like I just
I didn't want anyone I didn't want to
hear anyone's opinion about it like I
had already done the research I had
already made up my mind so I didn't want
to leave an opening for her to say oh
are you sure you want to do like I was
sure I wanted to do this and so when I
told her I was so blunt and now I look
back and I'm like I was so rude and mean
I was I was 18. I just said I'm gonna go
and shoot porn and I don't care what you
think you know and it's like I didn't
need to say it like that but I felt like
at the time been shamed or something or
yeah I was just like this is this is
what I want to do and I'm going to do it
and she was worried for all the reasons
that any mother would be worried I was
only 18. I'd never been overseas by
myself before I was going to be flown
over the other side of the world to the
states that is that if you're in
Australia is is America like the place
to go yes okay yes I mean like La
specifically is the headquarters of porn
production nice yes that's it globally
so yeah baby
Burbank yep
Pawn Valley
so it's actually amazing because I know
when a stu so when you're shooting
shooting in studios or
um you can tell which ones were built as
porn stages because they have the most
bathrooms so I was just shooting this
show Cooper's bar it was um that Ray C
horn she's on Better Call Saul she
played my um friend on my sitcom she's
brilliant and we're shooting out in uh
Canoga Park California and it was like
super spread out and there's bathrooms
in truly every room every hallway and
that's where you're like oh this is porn
yeah we got to prepare they put in extra
bathrooms yeah
but that's that's part of the reason why
La is the perfect place for porn because
we can piggyback off the Hollywood
industry as well I mean obviously you
guys are yeah
you guys actually make money you get to
keep it
your CEOs don't have Yachts while you
live in an apartment A gardener well
things have changed now because of only
fans I think you know it's it's gotten
better for performers yeah I want to
hear I want to get really dig into that
um my just question is like are you
studying a porn star are you looking up
to someone the same way as a comedian I
was looking I looked up to actually a
lot of non-comedians too I like I kind
of was like I know I want to be an
Entertainer and like I looked up to
Dennis Rodman I looked up to Adam
Sandler I looked up to you know but also
you know Richard Pryor and George Carlin
whatever were there entertainers Danny
Ash Danny Danny Ash was like she was the
first big internet star she was also
um a woman with big natural breasts and
for me like I I was praying for big
boobs so when they finally came I was
like finally my ticket to sex did you
ever get male attention that felt like
um negative you know the male attention
I I loved getting male attention and now
I look back at some of the attention I
got and I'm like that was actually
creepy but at the time I loved it I
loved getting older male attention yeah
so yeah but now I look back and I'm like
why were you what are you I was like
just because I liked the lollipop
doesn't mean you should have given it to
me a weirdo no there were there are many
situations where at the time I thought
this is cool and now I look back and I'm
like you were 40. and I was 14 and what
were we doing like Australia yeah
descended from criminals is that true
though really yeah yeah yeah like yeah
but I think that's some of the most
incredible Talent comes from Australia I
think because of that that criminal DNA
punk rock DNA that's right we have punk
rock yeah so you're looking up to Danny
I'm looking up to Danny and not just
because of the boobs she was she she
built an Empire she is the first
internet Queen she created a business
she became a millionaire from just doing
what she wanted to do for expressing
herself and showing her body and like
she was a boss so that's who I looked up
to I was always like I'm gonna make my
own money I'm gonna build my own Empire
I'm gonna produce and direct and I'm
gonna make I'm gonna own my content did
you ever think about stripping or any I
I did for a little while I it just I I
didn't like it I yeah there was a lot
like yes I I like to go to bed early
yeah I also I'm not I'm not good at
hustling in that I'm not good at
hustling people yeah like I'm very I'm a
very hard worker but um that that
interaction where you've got to try and
get money from people like it's much
easier in porn I'm just like yeah and
the money comes like I do what I love
and the money flows right it's
attraction not like like yeah yeah I
just I just wasn't great at it to be
honest
um so yeah I did that for maybe six
months stripping is such an art like I
mean it is like I go to strip clubs to
study I mean I learn as a performer I
learned so much just like the cut like
you just have to you are the shit like
you just have to enter into that reality
and you know and when the girls don't
you can tap like watching strippers that
are kind of just like not into it or
kind of giving a lot but you can tell in
their eyes they're not into it I'm like
sometimes I do that on stage where I'm
like giving it all but the eyes like you
gotta be there you got like you gotta
and if you're not like doing it for the
Love of the Game too yeah it's always
going to be I feel like a uphill yeah
yeah I wasn't my thing and I I also did
porn before I did stripping so that was
something I tried afterwards because I
was like oh I'm so interested in sex and
sex work why don't I try this I'm sure
I'll love it and I feel like I'd lose an
Achilles heel you know yeah yeah so then
you're getting into the industry like in
the beginning was there you know like
any business that is sort of your uh you
know sole proprietor like was there you
know I went to like open mics and you
know you're dealing with people that are
kind of like not at the top yeah that
are sort of sketchy and Shady like
that's not just a porn thing that in the
beginning people take advantage of you
and things aren't professional and
whatever did you have like some rough I
was really lucky that I started with a
really professional company you know I
really did vet like every company that I
worked for I did all the research that I
could on them I would like ask people I
would ask around like what are they cool
to work with so I I was a diligent
researcher
um there was a period in the beginning
where
um I just did go go so I wasn't ready to
do boy girl so I I took my every step in
my career I took at my own pace like it
didn't matter what kind of pressure I
was getting from other people like oh
you could make more money doing this
the way I've made my decisions I've got
this like fuckier mentality it's like am
I fucking a principle right so if I
think about something and my answer
isn't fuck yeah then I don't do it like
if there's any kind of niggling thought
like and so like if it's not a hell yes
it's a no exactly I love it and so
that's in the beginning
um when I would think about boy girl
where did you learn that to trust your
gut I don't know I really don't know I
just
you know I I guess like when there's a
niggling thing that I'm like even if I
can't put my finger on why I'm not ready
for something that niggling thing is
just so strong that I can't do it like I
just can't God that is like a darwinian
fucking Advantage because for me if
there's like a if I'm like oh someone's
asked me to do this like if I say no
what if they don't ask again and what if
I'm missing this opportunity and then
I'll force myself to do something
against me and be like why you're just
being scared you're just being you know
trepidatious because you're insecure and
I'll like throw myself into things I'm
like I knew I shouldn't have done that
why didn't I just trust my gut so I'm
fine it's taking me so long to get to
that point how amazing that you had it
that young yeah I don't know I don't
know where that came from to even say it
like I think for most people it's like
even if I can't explain to you why or
what's going on the answer is just no
yeah I wish I had a perfectly eloquent
explanation but like my gut saying no is
enough information for me that's awesome
yeah so yeah so I did um
I I performed for other companies for a
number of years and then I realized that
even though that was a lot of fun if I
wanted to bring my own vision of
sexuality to life and fuck how I wanted
to fuck and wear what I wanted to wear I
was going to have to create my own
production company so when you're doing
it for someone else do they give you the
scenario they give you the scene they
give you the everything and you kind of
so you still have final say you can
obviously you can say yes or no to
anything I didn't know that was obvious
oh you can you can say yes or no to
anything obviously okay not obviously
you can set you I'm telling you you can
say yes or no to anything
um so for example I'll be told my screen
Partners ahead of time if for some
reason I don't want to shoot with them
I'll say let's let's try someone else
there's you also want to be a team
player so they might say we're going to
put your hair in curls I don't like my
nowadays you won't see my hair you're
like peep for this one yeah I'm like no
there are certain things that I won't
play I won't do anything like I've
rejected a lot of scripts when there's
any kind of like slut shaming or even if
it's like slut shaming of a different
form of sex work like I refuse to and
what does that look like like within it
sled shaving within
um like like looking down at someone
who's like um doing other forms of sex
work maybe they're an escort or a
stripper or calling like if there's a
line line in a script where I call a
stripper a slut or something I'm just
like that kind of thing I'm just like I
won't do that
um you know certain scenarios like but
when you shoot for yourself you choose
everything from why is it that I don't
like it when some someone calls someone
else a slut but if you don't call me a
slut while we're having sex I will never
have sex with you again that's a
different
that's a different thing it's contextual
in the bedroom
I'm a dirty little slut
not on the street no in the bedroom in
my home that I worked hard to pay for
it will it should be said yes that is
the only time it should be said but see
that's boundaries and consent
that's the difference the stranger on
the street saying that you're a dirty
little slut that is not cool it's well
it's just like little little thank you
that's all I hear
[Music]
so you're like I need to because this is
I mean we have a very similar
trajectory business-wise you know I got
into comedy and I'm doing other people's
shows and I'm like I'm never gonna be
able to do what I do within this I can't
fit in here yeah I'm not pretty enough
to be the pretty girl I'm not weird
enough to be the girl like there were
all these like categories for actresses
and you know so you created your own
category well yeah I have no choice yeah
it was sort of like the same but see I
was also in my body type like I was sort
of like
um too curvy for mainstream but not
quite big enough for Baby W yeah so I my
body type like now thick is in now we
have a word first what do you think that
is do you think it's Kardashian uh I'm
sure that had something to do with it
yeah hey y'all Did you know 35 of all
fatal accidents occur between 6 p.m and
midnight people aged 25 to 35 have the
highest amount of drivers involved in
car crashes people aged 15 to 24 had the
highest rate of emergency room visits
due to car accidents of all age groups
if you're ever injured you can check out
Morgan and Morgan submitting an injury
claim with Morgan and Morgan is so easy
it's more like using an app than hiring
a lawyer because let's be honest that's
a goddamn nightmare submitting a claim
to Morgan Morgan is as easy as
pretending you didn't see that 5 PM
email from your boss with Morgan and
Morgan submitting a claim is as easy as
hitting snooze on your alarm for the
eighth times submitting a claim to
Morgan and Morgan is as easy as kicking
your friend with an Android off the chat
once you see their bubble come up green
Morgan and Morgan is America's largest
injury firm they have over 100 offices
Nationwide and more than 800 lawyers
with over 15 billion dollars were
covered for clients Morgan and Morgan
has a proven track record of fighting to
get you full and fair compensation if
you're ever injured you can check out
Morgan and Morgan their fee is free
unless they win for more information go
to forthepeople.com Whitney or dial
pound law pound
529 from your cell phone that's for for
the people.com Whitney or pound law
pound 529 from your cell phone this is a
paid advertisement but all the money
goes to my other legal fees so that was
the body type thing and I was like hi I
don't quite necessarily tell you that or
you just go like in the metrics or the
numbers you're like I'm not
hitting uh it I mean I in Australia
we're kind of like 10 years behind when
it comes to porn like so wherever we are
in the US like you show up to the porn
set with fucking a giant Bush of pews
everyone's like ah well they who invited
Bigfoot when like America was starting
to accept like thicker girls like I was
modeling in Australia and they still
wanted like they wanted stick thin
bolt-ons but I don't feel like that's
what men want
well I think men want everything and I
think that there's a there's a body type
for every man I think like Hollywood
then maybe like Hollywood like didn't
understand like the executives that were
running Hollywood they want anorexic
like 22 year olds but people don't you
know what I mean the internet
democratized everything that's what
you're into you're gay you know I'm
sorry
um but uh but yeah so it's like you know
and this is something else I learned
when I was doing all the research for
the robot which is the robot Factory the
requests that come in for the custom
dolls the sex dolls is uh part of the
reason they're struggling so much is
that
um the requests are usually to have
girls that are bigger they want bigger
asses bigger size yours is already so
heavy yeah
they're just so cumbersome they're more
heavy than they're heavier than a human
I think so and like
dead weight yeah humans like help you
care even it's like it's like carrying a
drunk girl out of the bar I mean it's
just truly dead weight so there's that
they request uh nipples that are as big
as the boob darker nipples all the stuff
that you would not think would be the uh
socially constructed standard of beauty
oh I think I think yeah I mean being in
Pawn I think the internet democratized
pornography like we actually saw what
people wanted which was everything yeah
everything out of the sun Pawn gets
blamed a lot that's this myth like the
anti-porn feminists always talk about oh
you know like the rise of labiaplasty is
because of porn it's like have you
actually watched porn some of the top
performers have really long meaty lips
like it's not porn focus on the
labioplasties in South Africa on the
kids how about those maybe focus on
those
but um yeah I can't remember what the oh
it was like creating my company so that
then I could uh actually create the pawn
that I wanted where the things I wanted
help like did you
um so uh in the beginning no I did
everything I edited my own movies I mean
obviously so I was coming across here
and I was I had my cruise here in La so
I would pick the videographer I wanted
to pick the photographer that I wanted
I'd pick the male and female talent I
wanted the makeup artist like I could do
everything from the minute detail and
then I would go back home and edit all
the content and create the product that
I really wanted to see what I wanted to
see in porn
oh nice yeah do you did you watch porn
at the top like would you watch it or
see what other people were doing I
watched a lot of Pawn yeah both for my
own pleasure and as market research you
know
I was studying yeah I mean I just love
the idea that's like like female
comedians being competitive like
watching each other's stuff being like
Oh God I was gonna do that like oh no
well when it comes to sex it's like
there's only there's only so many
different positions you can do it's
really what you bring to those positions
and when this is a very weird question
and I like today I was like don't ask
her that but I think I should which is
um
it's very clear why you're as famous as
you are and successful as you are but
why do you think you're such a star in
does that make sense or why do you think
people are so drawn to you I think it's
because I love what I do I think it's
because I'm passionate about it I really
and that's clear and it comes through
yeah which you know not to shame anyone
who does it for the money we all have to
that's fine for the money but it's like
stand up I did it like I was like I will
do this for a hundred dollars a week for
the rest of my life like yeah I was like
if I make money at this great but in the
beginning I was not making money like I
was not it really was just like a
supplemental income I was not it wasn't
my career in the beginning did you work
any other jobs while you were uh I mean
I was studying most of the time so I
mean in the end the money that I made
from porn was a lot compared to what
everyone else was doing like working at
the University cafe or whatever but you
know I didn't have a lot of money it
wasn't until only fans that I really
started to make big big money like I
just did it because I loved it
so hold on so you're doing films you're
doing your own stuff only fans comes
along was that five years ago
um I feel like during the pandemic is
when that's when it started cracking
yeah but I want to say I think I had an
account in in 2018 I think but I I
posted a couple of things it wasn't it
wasn't really big I was so focused on
producing and and performing in studio
porn that I wasn't focused on it at all
so I don't know that many people were
making big big money on only fans until
it blew up in 2020. before that that you
were
grinding on before it was like Angela
white.com that was my own website now
like now only fans are so lucrative that
URL just links straight to only fans
because running your own website comes
with a whole bunch of costs like hosting
and yeah so now it's just like well just
go to my only fans but yeah your website
should be angelaway.edu I learn a lot
it's very educational
um so only fans comes along and is this
like your first year trepidatious but
what are the like I mean
explain what only fans has done for the
sex work community and why it's so
crucial uh it's given it's really
empowered performers it's um for many
performers it's been this source of
income that allows them to have more
options and make more choices you know
like I am
lucky that I've been in a position for a
long time to to make decisions when it
comes to say like I can choose who I
work with and or I feel like I can
choose anyone can are there certain
performers that you just like have
really good chemistry with even though
it's not if it's not like but you can
still say like good game after oh yeah
oh yeah there's I mean the the chemistry
ranges from like oh my God like I love
this person too like oh they're a good
friend and I can fuck them and we can
give Mutual pleasure but it's not like
it's not like I want to have dinner with
them or anything right sure sure you
know like give me the dick and then
there's actually quite a few like that
that I'm just like I really like them as
people but I just often tell everyone to
hear you speak yeah
um so there's that so there's that and
and
um there's actually very few people that
I don't have some kind of connection
with whether it's sort of like you know
on this on the Friendship spectrum and
um if if I just have absolutely zero
chemistry with someone then they'll end
up on my no list just because I don't
want to go to like sex I don't want sex
to become a chore for me yeah so if we
have sex and I just can't find anything
like and it's usually if if they're just
not present at all like if they can't be
in the scene with me because you need to
be in this space between us if you're
over there I mean everyone has a bad day
I don't you know if it's just a one-off
whatever but if you're not really
engaging in the sex and with me in some
capacity then I can't find a way to
connect with you and then I'm having
disconnected sex and then I feel
horrible and oh you know I just uh yeah
I don't want to be like machine like
robots fucking yeah yeah that's my brand
okay I will sue you if you start doing
that okay that is you already did the
Two Broke Girls porn so we're
we're pushing it on the copyright
infringement I'll send the robots to you
but
is there do you wow that's fascinating
to me with checking out during that is
such a bummer when you feel like
someone's checked out during sex and
you're just like a blow up doll and
you're like what are we doing like I
feel like you're just jerking off with
me with my pussy yeah but do you ever
worry that because I'll watch porn
sometimes I'm like oh they're falling in
love oh my God like I'll watch like
sometimes like when James Dean did that
movie with I think was Lindsay Lohan oh
yeah back in the day I like got really
into his like things ah I get really
into his like videos and I'd watch him
and I'd be like he's in love with her
they're in love and then I watch another
I'm like oh he's cheating on her like
he's is that part of his appeal to he's
so intense and it's like so but how are
you guys not falling in love I don't get
it I'm too much of a Love sometimes it's
the worst yeah always it's a really
dangerous Kink but sometimes that's the
craziest thing I've done in a porno he's
fallen in love for sure like that's like
that's the thing I'm like they have nine
she has nine dictionary but they're
falling in love oh that is psycho it
makes the sex so much better though like
when you have that kind of strong Crush
connection whatever it is that because
if you're gonna make a woman come you
have to want you have to be want her to
do you have to like really pull a hammy
this you know but there's a lot of guys
in porn that want to make you come but
it's still there then you they're not in
love with you they're just it might be
maybe it's an ego thing you come if
you're not emotionally connected
yes but it's better if I'm if it's
easier and better if I'm emotionally I'm
like I can make people laugh with a joke
I don't believe in yeah but
yeah I would I feel weird I'd be like
well if I do do that yeah I can
definitely I can come because like as
long as the motion is how it needs to be
I can still come yeah but yeah obviously
like using a sex toy or something yeah
yeah do you ever fantasize during scenes
about something else or does that make
it seem like you're elsewhere
um no I usually yeah I'm usually within
the scene itself because I think that's
when you make the best scenes like when
you're truly connecting with your
partner like finding a way to really
like yeah look into their soul and like
find a spot where we're both in in it
together right right have you ever like
been in a scene it's not and you're just
like we have to reset there was actually
okay so this was probably my worst day
on set and it's not even that bad but um
so I it was from my own production so I
hand picked this male talent and I had
done my market research I'd watched a
bunch of his scenes and I was really
excited to fuck him so
I was so excited so we we got like all
do you textbook did you talk before do
you no no no no no no sometimes it's
better not to yeah because you I don't
know him personally and like sometimes
you don't want to learn too much about
them because you just want the sex to be
good yeah yeah yeah
um anyway we shot the sex Stills and we
were we started shooting the sex scene
and like he
wasn't fucking me like he had been
fucking in his other scenes
and I was like oh my God he's trying to
be this other guy so like
okay so there's like some Top Male
performers like every well like
I don't want to like name names or like
play any favorites but there's there's
just some there's some male performers
in the industry that everyone loves and
he was literally using his moves and
fucking me like him because he knew that
I loved fucking this other guy and I was
like whoa like wait I hope he's doing
the movies
yes he's doing the thing yes that's a
fucking thing you know what you know
what I go through I go through fucking a
guy that's not a porn star who's trying
to copy those moves that's awful it's
I'm so sorry it's like no this was the
this was one of the only scenes I ever
had to cut in and like I I cut because I
was like so confused because I was so
excited to fuck him when did you figure
it out like within 10 minutes she was he
was studying you and probably seeing
what you like seeing who I liked fucking
and was like oh I'm gonna fuck her like
he fucks her because that's what she
likes and I was watching his scenes and
being like I can't wait to fuck him so
it was like my brain was like what is
happening and it was actually I actually
had to take I caught and like I just say
it claimed that I needed to use the
restroom and I actually had a little
tear I was like because I was like I
felt like he wasn't there with me like
his like he was pretending to be someone
he wasn't and so I'm like I'm you're not
even having we're not even having sex
you're you're being someone else who am
I fucking and so I had to give myself a
little pep talk and get back out there
and fuck that dude but I was like never
what did Angela White pep talk in the
bathroom look like you're serious that
on some like Mom's spaghetti shit like
what exactly happens in that moment I
was like okay okay this isn't how you
had planned he's not fucking you the way
you want it but he's still fucking you
well so like you know just maybe Embrace
what's happening and maybe just pretend
the other dude is fucking you or like
yeah you know can you say to him in that
moment like hey I feel like you're I
would now yeah this was like in the
beginning when I was directing and so I
was still like I it's very delicate with
male performers because they you have to
keep the erection right you need oh yeah
direction will kill an erection yeah you
don't want to say anything that's going
to get in his head and then you don't
say anything period a woman talking that
erection will be gone say some dirty
things
I'm lost yeah can you help me find uh
I'm confused help me fuck me help me
like that have you ever had a situation
where an erection goes away and you have
to
pull out a photo of me
all the time works every time
um so yeah sometimes erections leave
it's usually an environmental Factor
I've found so if it's too hot which
often it is in porn Valley
hate is just Kryptonite for a boner like
immediate boner goes down so that's
that's an easy fix that's a cut let's
blast the air conditioning they're doing
they're they're doing the blue chew some
of them some of them are so they're our
natural guys that don't use anything and
then there are guys that use like
whatever Viagra Cialis Bluetooth
um and then there are some guys that
inject a cabbage act and then cabbage
act promo code Whitney
and then there are some although not as
much as like there's been a bunch of
podcasts lately that are like claiming
that everyone in porn has a penis
implant not not true at all like very
few let the men believe that what is
that squad's not gonna make them feel
better I think that that rumor is not
for you guys do you know how many less
School shooters we've had because that
was going rumor was going around oh you
guys need to believe that they are
implants right got it it's like how
women are able to go well she's got
plastic surgery like that's how you just
you know what I mean okay I'm sure
people need to believe that well I
shouldn't have said that there are some
men that are natural because that's
going to crush some people people you
know Viagra when was that invented like
the the 80s or something I feel like
it's like a minute yeah but they were
you know Pawn was being produced without
Viagra for a while so there's still some
like old school guys that just really
perverted that can get it up in front of
a bunch of men and like fuck for hours
with no assistance so it's possible yeah
those men do exist there and as long as
you're there I feel like good homes I
feel like the right women are in the
room the right temperature and it was
like guys can we quiet I feel like I
could take that boner down pretty fast
you'd be surprised how many men love a
dominant woman you know what love love
I'm learning this yeah so I'm learning
what area are you not does not turn you
on sexually
what area like what area you're like not
for me not my thing threesomes were fine
with yeah like what is not turn what
doesn't turn you on and what is it
pretty much everything turns me on
except for the illegal stuff you know
like everything consensual like I'm down
for different Kinks
um
um have you gone through phases with
Kinks yeah for sure
um I'm not a super pain slut like I like
being dominated but more a psychological
domination like actually being in
physical pain isn't my like like some
girls love to be bruised up and marked
I'm like just like you know yeah my
daddy but you don't have to like hit me
that high yeah yeah yeah yeah I think I
dated a guy it was like I mean the Dom
sub thing I I'm very into it I just
I need some breaks sometimes you know
it's just not sustainable if you have a
job you don't want like a lifestyle 24
7. well it's like it's like you can only
have six blueberries for lunch it's like
well I'm at the airport is or is
honeydew okay like I found a a fruit cup
and Starbucks like it's like when it's
like like dated someone that was that
and I'm into it it's like having your
own personal trainer and like yeah no
it's just but someone tries to restrict
my eating that's just not we're not I
don't think it was about being thin or
anything because I think he was actually
like thought I was too it was a control
thing it was yeah I think it was more
that like showing loyalty and that which
I think is hot I'm actually very beta in
my personal life which is probably a lot
of people wouldn't believe in like I
think because I emasculate Man by
accident like I'm not trying to it's
just like my personality and like the
tone of my sure last voice but so I was
like for a while I was like oh I'm gonna
have to do this like if I do super Alpha
guys that are like Doms and I'll be in
this like sub thing but it just was like
I can't sit in the corner all day like I
gotta can I have my laptop at least if
I'm gonna be sitting in the corner naked
tied up can you just not tie up my arm
like I just have to return can you like
I needed a sub like I need a sub to do
all the stuff that I can't do because
I'm yours up you know what I mean and
like
um so it was like it was just wasn't
like did you see the movie secretary no
I didn't James Spader and Maggie
Gyllenhaal's old old movie and it's
about that like it's like that domsub
hot thing okay well then yeah I'm only
into that within the bedroom no like you
can't try and control my life outside of
it or I would just go nuts yeah I mean
it's just a lot of like I'm also such a
klutz like about that kind of stuff like
I just I I'm too literal if it's like go
you know get on your knees and it's like
for how how long I just I just can you
just put in the calendar I I just it's
it seems I need a schedule I guess it
seems but there was something hot about
that but I was like this is just not
something that is sustainable yeah you
couldn't negotiate that just being like
bedroom time hmm
it it felt I guess not I just was I was
in a place where I felt like I could not
be in a relationship because I was just
accidentally to Alpha or too
emasculating to men or two so I just
like within it I was like oh I finally
have this thing and it's someone that he
was very like proactive and was like
this is where we're going to dinner and
this is what we're doing and I really
need it I really want that but I think
people
tend to get deferential with me because
I am
whatever
um
Alpha in a lot of ways but in my
relationship I really am more beta but I
don't know how to convince people of
that so I think I was going through this
phase of like oh I guess I need to date
these like 50 Shades of Gray dudes then
you know are making me like fucking
putting asparagus in my butt all day
that what didn't happen Okay well you
never know I just but a lot of the
pinching and shit is like I want you to
hurt when you sit down tomorrow to think
about me and I'm like I have a standing
desk
buddy
I
there's a lot of things in the Dom sub
like in Fifty Shades of Gray that you
don't like
that I have I've I've worked hard I've
built something I have employees you
know what I mean like it's he's like I
want you to dress up please be and clean
that cleaning clean the house I'm like
dude I have a cleaning lady it's clean
like I'm not late you know what I mean
which all always like the cleaning lady
fantasy always just feels like it's like
did you just trick me into cleaning the
house yeah
or like I remember it was one time like
I want you to come home and I want you
to be cleaning the house and like it's
like a cleaning lady outfit or something
and I just was like well I do you want
me to ask Leslie for her Crocs in
Aeropostale t-shirt I mean my cleaning
lady just she's wearing a Canal Street
fake Gucci shirt I mean I could just she
doesn't wear a Frenchman outfit no then
it was like the make French maid outfit
which is like oh yeah because French
people are known for being so clean but
um I got really paranoid because I've
been with my cleaning lady for 15 years
she's like my family and I was like if
she finds a cleaning lady outfit I'm
worried she's gonna think I'm cheating
on her with other cleaning ladies she's
the one that's gonna have to wash it
like I can't I just I can't deal with
the embarrassment I I have to be able to
make eye contact with Leslie yeah fair
enough you know what I mean so I can't
you know but I you know I want to be
that Adventure I just couldn't that
wasn't a match can I ask you a couple oh
you just wiped a mascara across here I
this is the part of the show yeah where
my eyes start I start turning into Jack
Sparrow you've wiped it like all the way
down huh oh I turned am I in full black
face am I canceled do I get it no yeah I
put on an eyeliner for you being in this
on the same screen as you is truly my
nightmare so let's just get to it is
squirting pee is there P how why can't I
squirt why am I peeing am I do I have to
practice what's happening dehydrated I
think the whole squirting thing is just
putting more pressure on women like who
cares are you coming if you're coming
who cares if you're schooling it's a
different kind it's a different kind
it's a different feeling
do you like the way that you're feeling
when you come right now if a guy uh yes
good I just mean this like I can do it
if a guy uses his finger and he's going
like this yep and it'll happen and it
feels good but it's I don't know if it
feels good because I'm like I did it I'm
not yeah I'm a human octopus I feel like
literal orgasms are more intense yeah
like but I have not been able to have
those without a toy or my hands
a clitoral yeah because you're how would
you yeah well okay cat position that's
my favorite position excuse me Pat gotta
do cat uh-oh coital alignment technique
that's what it stands for cat position
so the cat is where you're going to I
thought you meant it was the cat
position you just like ignore someone
who's nice to you and rudely ruin their
furniture that would be hot too
that sounds hot but this is a different
cat position this is okay so you're
going to
um angle your pelvis up so you could put
like a cushion underneath your your
lower back my pillow your yes and then
basically it's the man is going to be on
top or I mean you could do it with a
woman but like you're gonna have him rub
up against your pubic Mound and his
pubic Mound so he is so deep in you and
rubbing so he's actually rubbing the
clit instead of his because this is what
this is sex usually right the man is
just like yeah yeah in and out so his
cock is going in and as he's fully in
he's touching your clit for a second and
he yeah and then like high five yeah
he's just slapping it feels good but
it's not going to be enough
um stimulation to make you come so cat
is where he goes in deep he stays in
deep and he's kind of instead of moving
up and down like that that is my shit
but a lot of women don't they can can
never have an internal orgasm clitoris
is like I had to be on top of the guy on
a chair I was also I was like very young
where I was like 24 when it happened
oddly it was at an acting class
um
[Laughter]
it was like we were rehearsing Like a
Villain rehearsing a sex scene we're
rehearsing like a Philadelphia Story and
by the way a side note this was an
acting school that I later found out was
like a Scientology feeder school like it
was like a line with Scientology
whole other conversation so my Kink is
Scientology nothing gets me off like a
like a cult that uh makes babies on a
boat uh uh audit their failures
um but it was like I was on top of him
on a chair but I feel like now that I'm
perceived in a way that's really Alpha I
can't like be on top anymore it's it I
know that sounds like stupid but it's
like guys already think I'm like this
top fuck that lean into it
lean into it get on the chair
just do it if it's going to give you an
internal orgasm
it's I don't know if I could do it again
but
it was uh it was like it was did you it
was like surprised me like it was so
you're sitting on the chair
are you sure you're not getting clitoral
stimulation because if he's sitting you
know what if y'all
yes and I feel like I was very close to
him and it was very like if you're on
just like one one chair like a little
chair I think you're also grinding your
clit at the same time and I hadn't gone
on Prozac yet so I was very OCD you know
um but no I'm thank God not on those
because that's the other thing I think a
lot of people are on antidepressants and
stuff that have side effects that mess
with your ability to that's the other
thing is that first then by the time I
got out of those relationships that
weren't sexually satisfying because of
whatever reason I couldn't connect
Etc that's the other thing emotional
connection is such a big part of it for
me yeah and I I wasn't ready to be
intimate with people or Surrender like I
still like had walls up you know
emotionally it's like and I didn't feel
um
uh I didn't want to give that to some I
didn't want to get addicted to someone I
didn't want to give someone the power of
making me feel that good because I think
I saw so many I grew up I think around a
lot of sex addiction around like
marriages being destroyed so and I think
for me I thought like Ugh if I like sex
too much it's gonna destroy my life or
something subconsciously you know but
that was my own dumb bullshit yeah
I love that we can just stare at each
other
I literally went up my nose I have made
out with your mic by the way I think you
have my lipstick please if you know I'm
putting that mic on eBay
um what uh uh when you're not having sex
for work what I'm fascinated it's like
my favorite thing to ask a chef is where
do you eat you know entertainers what do
you listen to what do you watch like so
when you're having sex Just For the Love
of the Game yeah what does it look like
I have to have a connection with someone
absolutely like and it's much more
intimate like when we shoot for porn
we're opening up for the light for the
camera some of the positions are a lot
more distant so cat I'm like get on top
of me I want skin to skin contact I want
you all over me like I want every part
of my skin touching every part of your
skin is it by the way choreographed like
do you kind of have the list of
positions laid out beforehand it depends
on the company and it depends on the
type of scene so my favorite type of
seeing a Gonzo scene which is like you
just fuck the way you want to fuck
there's very little Direction it's just
all about raw chemistry connections
able to sleep with people you work with
outside of work or is that it's better
if I don't yeah yeah it's just better to
keep the tension to keep the tension
because like if you have really good
sexual chemistry with someone and then
you fuck them off camera and then you
learn more about them and you realize
you actually don't like them as a person
like it's just bad it's a big thing and
acting too if you see like two people
that have horrible chemistry as actors
like sometimes it means they fucked you
know yeah I worked with this guy like a
really good actor
um and he we like sort of had this
flirtation in the beginning and he's
like we cannot hook up we can knock it
up I'm like why not you know whatever
and he was like because it's gonna ruin
and he was so right yeah yeah you know
it it fucks with the tension you want to
keep that sexual tension for onset don't
don't fuck the person on and then
there's all these issues like okay so
say you like stop fucking someone off
camera or you start dating them and then
you break up and it's a bad breakup and
then like you don't want to get booked
with them and then what if like say a
male Talent has to cancel on the day and
they're like oh who can we replace him
with and the only person that replace
them with is your ex-boyfriend and
you're like I don't wanna it's like
don't don't show where you're at exactly
it's better not to yeah so there are
some positions
um
hate to say it reverse cowgirl because I
really don't like that position but
sometimes when I'm taking a dick in my
answer in reverse cowgirl and the dick
is really straight it'll be hitting my
G-spot through my arms oh yeah by the
way that's another recent discovery I've
never had sex with a guy until recently
that has a very straight dick straight
yeah because most of them are curved
right because didn't they the um they
don't call me ho Rogan for nothing but
in tribal times uh the guy's dicks
evolved to be curved to scoop out the
semen of the competing
I thought that was the the head like the
mushroom head like the little so the
head goes like this and then like the
more mushroomy it is I feel like you're
right yeah because there's the yeah
pull that come out
dude I feel very lucky that we aren't
alive at a time we're not just
constantly getting raped by mushroom
dicks scooping semen out of us
constantly the fact that a dick evolved
just to scoop out fresh calm how often
were women getting fucked Jesus guys
um that sounds like a dream to me
arrived
I feel like every woman had a fucking
hard UTI at the time I feel it's just
like a
do you have a protocol for UTI
management I would say that your vagina
just gets
um better at handling stuff like the
more yeah gives up no just like no why
bother no I mean I've never been really
prone to the guy thankfully I bet too
they do yeah most of them thankfully I
got in the biggest fight I mean this guy
bless his heart I just like you have got
to wash your dick oh you have to watch I
think and the asshole even if you're not
playing with the asshole because it just
it it just the smell stays most white
people don't even wash their legs
or backs they you know that most people
just just wash their hair and they go oh
no it drips down it's cleaning it's no
you have to scrub it you have to wash it
exfoliation in it gotta get that
exfoliation
yeah get it
yes yeah
so this male friend was not washing his
penis he yeah it just was blessed it's
just we I got so into we I have not had
sex like that like I just got so it we
were having sex like very frequently and
it was just in between not you got to
cut your nails you got to clean under
your nails guys so I just cut you've got
a file file Cuts Like if you're gonna
put your finger inside a gal you gotta
get that mani pedi like it's even like
the the cuticles and like around the
skin around because that um can get
really hard as well especially on men
and that can be scratching and it's
weird because I'm so into a guy that's
like rugged and not like you know most
guys in La have more cosmetics and
makeup and hair Pomade than I do so it's
like hot that someone's like rugged and
kind of a feral animal but then you're
like you have to well rugged but get a
manicure and wash your bowls and your
dick and your butthole yep yep
and you can't go back and forth from
tush to vagina
well you can't you can probably I do but
in the regular sex don't do it in the
streets yeah the civilians without a
plan don't do it yeah you got to have a
plan if you're gonna do it you can't be
slappy about it yeah because going back
and forth that'll give you a yeast
infection or a UTI yeah yeah yeah we
have plans if you're Rogue about it yeah
agreed you know what I mean agree I'm
going to look at the questions that the
fan sent in I cannot wait to see but for
me another question for me is there a
way to not queef like is there uh some
kind of yes okay so this is the trick
right so you can feel when air has gone
up there right yeah you totally know I'm
like if I turn you can feel my turn this
is gonna go real whoopee cushion real
fast so this is what you do and this is
how you do it so the guy doesn't even
know what you're doing make it sexy
right like what like just no no no no
I'm gonna
that's it that's ridiculous so big made
so much space it's talking to you baby
it says fuck me
let me translate
it says that dick is so good fuck more
Aaron to me
okay so when you know it's in when you
know it's in what you do is you take
your fingers you go down you start
masturbating you put your fingers inside
your pussy right
you pull up and you push lightly you
pull up so you open the hole you pull up
you push lightly it pushes all the air
out it doesn't make a sound because it's
not closed so it doesn't make that whoa
yeah so you did it they won't hear a
thing and it just looks like you're so
horny you stuck your fingers inside
you're like oh my God this is so good I
need that dick back inside me and you've
just pushed the air out nobody knows
fingers in so it's like so it's this
it's like
you've opened up the hole you open the
hole done whoa dude that is some Pro
shit yeah nothing makes shit go sideways
like a and the other way you can do it
is like so and it's always like right
between songs Frank Ocean Pyramids
there's like a four second you've got
the Spotify there's a um what is it
where you can um make it so the songs
blend together because it's always that
three second like spot in between a song
and just like God damn it like happening
like I'm blasting Marilyn Manson look if
he's man enough to fuck you he's man
enough to hear a queef like you know
what I think also same thing with sex on
periods like if y'all aren't out there
having sex with girls in your periods
like you are gay but the other thing is
it's good if you like so stick your
fingers in and like finger yourself but
instead of in and out like up and down
just to let it open like yep keeping it
open it's like letting a bird out yeah
and you know when the Air's out and
you're good to go that is yes
a game changer hold on how do I go to
all the um also in doggy like when he
pulls his dick out don't relax your
pussy make sure you're squeezing those
kegels when he pulls out because if
you're relaxed the air is going to suck
right in uh
so you're in Doggy Dude kegels I do how
with something in there no just just
like the Benoit balls uh I
I have done them but honestly it's
usually just traffic lights that's my
Kegel time I'm like it's a good reminder
and you're holding for how long you
squeeze hold well as long as the red
light oh shit yeah hold do you live in
L.A so that pussy is tiny
but I would like to ask you what how do
you define love
and have you been in love yeah
it's a tough one because a lot of what
love is is a bunch of chemicals just
making you feel drugged ain't that the
truth that's a lot of oxytocin and
dopamine and adrenaline and there's a
lot going on internal drug cabinet that
actually like blinds you to what's in
front of you so I think
um tricks yeah yeah it does it's like I
mean there's a grade book
um it's called uh uh I know this is a
dorky corny name it's called Cupid's
poisoned Arrow good but
um the title is very extra but sort of
outlines that and what what orgasms were
intended for like orgasms like you know
are so it's so hard to make a woman come
the idea was that this is the most fit
partner the father of my child like all
these guys are gonna fuck me and the one
that fucks me the best Scoops out the
most come with the most mushroom yes
dick and who connects with me the most
intensely makes me come and the organism
sucks sucks you're more likely to get
pregnant yeah you have an orgasm so it
all sort of makes sense you know from an
evolutionary perspective
um
you know but what it does chemically
like just sort of how bonding yeah after
sex an orgasm a guy goes to sleep but
after an orgasm a man's uh sort of
Reptilian Brain
triggers rest whereas a woman is like up
and planning and plotting because the
idea is you're pregnant now I got a plot
I got a plan I gotta overthink I gotta
be neurotic I gotta be hypersensitive
you know so it's like that moment I
think I'm a man
I am entertaining the idea that I'm a
trans man I want to I want to cuddle and
go to sleep
and then well a nap a nap and then have
Multiplex I
agree yeah this is
making a lot of things way more clear
because the girl dating a girl
everything else you're gay now I'm like
no I'm a straight trans man
it's trapped in a woman's body that
looks like a trans woman
it's very complex
I happen to look like a trans woman but
I think I'm a trans man
who won't transition
it's just it seems like hard work I'm
here for you whatever you
whatever you decide you are so because
yeah you
like just the neurochemistry of that do
you feel like understanding that
takes the like romance of it all out
you're too smart for your own good uh no
because like even though even though you
can rationalize it you're still feeling
the feelings
um
those feelings will get you but I feel
like you've been able to
compartmentalize those feelings the the
emotional feelings the bonding the
oxytocin of it all which is the bonding
and then the being secure and sex
because a lot of times it's it gets
muddy
I still think it's like hard to fall in
love even if you have good sex with
someone at like afterwards you can be
like that was good sex but
I'm good to leave hmm I don't know do
you want a partner I've had plenty of
Partners
um I've had plenty of like good
relationships like good open polyamorous
relationships I love
I tried monogamy and I wasn't good at it
I really were I'm gonna be honest
there's just too much money in polyamory
so I tried monogamy and it kept me poor
yeah I just I'm I like to connect with
people sex is a conversation and I meet
someone new and I want to like get to
know them and I'm like I wonder how they
fuck like
laughs
I don't know I just I don't think
monogamy is for me I think monogamy
could be for me for around
um maybe 12 months okay I think I could
be obsessed with someone enough and bond
with them enough that I wouldn't need to
have sex with anyone else for 12 months
and then after that I'd be like okay
because then you get to work too does
work count does that count I don't I
don't think it counts personally so if
you are at work all day getting hammered
by dread yeah and come home are you like
that like
doesn't count it doesn't count to me I
mean it's like you want your partner to
have fun at work like I might still have
fun at work I might still gain sexual
pleasure but it's not the same as like
intimate love making that I have at home
it's not it's no yeah yeah yeah even
when I connect with people on set it's
never going to be the same like somebody
has a baby wipe afterwards it's a
performance yeah
it's look my aim in every scene is to
not perform that's the ultimate aim
that's like the Pinnacle like that's the
best porn sex when you are having sex
with that person as if there weren't
cameras that's it that's why you are you
we got it so but you can't get that in
everywhere we're out here you're acting
the least of any any woman having sex I
found myself like it's like with these
porn stars are look they're being fake
I'm like nah bitch I think I'm the one
being fake I'm over here like um that
feels like like
we fake it the ones that the great porn
stars you actually don't yeah I mean
look I'll be honest there are some
companies and certain directors that
heavily direct a scene like they'll tell
you we need an orgasm in every position
and we need these five positions in this
order those kind of things on anything
sometimes it'll be
um uh like the stats or whatever they
you know they know that this is popular
we need to get these positions in
um you know step brother stat yeah and
and the the orgasm in every position I
guess that's that's kind of catering to
every like every person's fantasy like
if you know there's the person that only
jerks off to doggy and so we want to
make sure that the female has an orgasm
in doggy because that's for that
particular viewer and there's the person
that only wants to watch the reverse
cowgirl so so I understand it but those
scenes aren't as conducive to real
orgasms because it's like right right
it's heavily directed but when you're on
a set and it's Gonzo and it's like fuck
however you want to fuck and you
actually have chemistry with that person
then you're gonna get real sex or as
real as it can can be like there's
always some sort of artifice you do have
to open up for the camera but I did the
scene that I'm probably the most well
known for is my scene with Manuel
Ferrara where you can look it up who can
I do spell his name uh Manuel
m-a-n-manuel yeah
um does if you write Angela White gets
emotional after creampie
I have had I mean
we fucked for an hour and then I cried
in his arm for 20 minutes
yeah it's like a meme now but did it but
that was what happened there the sex was
so intimate and so incredible and so
real like I just had this release I just
was crying for it was 20 or 30 minutes
it's all it was all filmed the camera
man just kept rolling
it's all in the scene we won best boy
girl sex scene for it like New York Post
wrote an article about it saying with
the headline porn will never get better
than this oh
it's like
a lot it's yeah it's
my I would say it's my best scene but
because it didn't feel like a scene so
while it was happening you didn't I
wasn't there like I was in the space
with Manuel I was with Manuel I wasn't
anywhere else I wasn't thinking of the
camera operator I wasn't thinking of the
light it was just we were connecting and
we were so in tune with each other's
bodies see this is blowing my mind
because it's like for this to be the
best scene the best to work it's like
there's this
stigma and porn that these women are
just getting fucking fucked and it's
it's like the maybe that's happening but
the ones that are popular and the ones
that are the most successful lucrative
Etc
the things people actually really want
to watch are the ones where the woman is
getting a tremendous amount of real for
real Z's pleasure that's the thing
people only will talk about the negative
impacts of porn well and that's the
thing like that's what it's clear right
now men are still the biggest consumers
of porn and that is changing like more
and more women are consuming porn and
being open about consuming porn and like
my biggest Spenders on only fans are
actually women but really yeah but like
men are speaking with their clicks like
they want to see porn where the women
are enjoying the sex
it's like that's his kink
but but it just the fact that that scene
is so popular shows that there are so
many men that they want they want to be
having connected sex they want to be
having sex with women that are enjoying
themselves that are like genuinely
connected with their sexual partner
that's what resonates this is like so
wild because it's it's the same as stand
up in a lot of ways but it's like you
see them
stand-ups the great stand-ups and then
the people that don't understand why
they're not making it and you're like
and I don't know how to say it but to
Comics that come out they've got great
jokes they've got a great sort of angle
they're smart it's like you're not
connecting with the audience yes you
have to fall in love with them yeah and
then they're all fucking shitty crowd
I'm like that's yeah you already or
haven't you have this adversity with the
crowd you have like this cantankerous
relationship with the crowd like it's
all energy yeah you know and it's like
it's it's so
this is
like this is kind of blowing my mind in
a way because it's just we're not
getting away with anything you're never
getting away with it so it's like it's
like the ultimate lesson and do what you
love yeah because if you don't love it
you're not going to get paid yeah this
is a great question oh this is such a
good favorite fragrance on a man
I missed what I do like I like fresh
sweat yeah yeah
a man who eats healthy
and like you know it's like taking care
of himself and then goes work if you
drink your sweat is gross no you've got
to be eating healthy not drinking
hydrated go work out that come back with
that fresh yeah
oh that's hot I will bury my nose in
your armpit I'll bury my nose off where
are you in shape guys are shaving you
don't like don't stop I don't just I
like some but I my pubes I feel like I
need to get a merkin
or plugs I kind of want pubes back yeah
if you laze it it's it's I lasered in
the early days yeah it was just like a
give up on that from Hardee's I mean my
it was like there was laser that was
it was not it was an easy bake oven they
would just put your pussy in an easy
recall the Easy Bake Oven yeah it's
fried it's done it's done it's like and
then when I try to grow it out it's like
a little like Smithers hairs yeah and
it's all like little white hairs and
it's yeah it's you yeah I I prefer a man
to leave his hair I also I just don't
like shaved pubes because they're spiky
that's it and then I want to grind on
your pizza area and it hurts and it's
you're gonna get an ingrown or it's it's
gonna be get red and inflamed and I'm
gonna think it's a herpe and then I'm
getting it all apparently I'm red and
inflamed because I'm grinding on you and
your sharp pointy like
just wait it's going back just leave it
you can trim it a little if you want
like but just don't yeah don't don't
shave it off I think I think it makes
their dicks look bigger maybe we know
how big your dick is
her garlic like you know when women line
outside their lip
people know we all know the difference
yeah we go oh look how overdrawn that
lip is same same yeah
um interesting what do you have thoughts
on the on PornHub in the state of Utah's
new law
um
that sucks I don't know what it is
um basically
um I'm not sure the exact details but
um PornHub uh just restricted access to
the whole entire state of Utah because
they were making it too difficult to
um a they they wanted age verification
but there's an issue with privacy I
don't know the full
um the full details of it I just don't
think that I mean it's all about
protecting the children but um
protecting the children oh in the state
where they marry children
oh don't they can't go to Pornhub but
they can marry 88 year old but people
who corpses are internet literate know
how to use a VPN
so I feel like better sex education and
age-appropriate requirements anyone who
wants to access an adult content site
has to be prove that they're 18. but
then you're stopping adults from being
adults and you're you're then having to
like there's like um
how do you feel as an adult like giving
away your private information and your
ID every time you want to watch oh so
it's like if you're doing it of age
you're having to yeah
like why aren't you using the parental
controls that I was gonna say why where
where are the parents
it's like yeah the internet is forever
you're the one that had the kid you
gotta watch it dude we gotta make know
where it is
you just do yeah
you know just get
um
but when you have 50 kids you can't
possibly know where they all are at one
time so Utah had to
do you want kids no thank you did you
always know that yeah I can't I yeah
from as long as I can remember I've
never wanted kids
yeah I'm just not interested I just
honestly I feel like firstly the world's
already overpopulated and secondly the
world is an absolutely horrible place I
don't want to be responsible for
bringing a child into this world and be
responsible for their suffering because
living is suffering
I'm Gonna Let You Go very against my
instincts she's looked me keep you
forever I have another podcast as long
in a very long time but we have to
finish editing the um uh uh roast of me
which you're gonna do the intro yes I'm
excited so so Angela is going to do the
intro that we're gonna put in the roast
of coffee comings and it's gonna
um should we show her the picture should
we show it to her it's basically gonna
be like uh ladies and gentlemen welcome
to the roast of Whitney Cummings please
welcome your host Hannah stocking okay
is that what we need Haley easy
yeah welcome to the rest Whitney
Cummings
yeah I think the other one was like and
now for your host and now for your host
Hannah stocking can we put that on
prompter and then
um what's up please stand by what was
that would you like that oh no it was
that two words too I said oh my God I
thought that was just came I thought
that it was just I said that was your
voice
that sounded like Siri sorry
that was wild is that good or was that
it was but it was like it sounded like a
robot please stand by that's wild
you know
Robert Green's argument about the aliens
is that
it wouldn't uh is that aliens wouldn't
be able to make it to Earth because the
distance is so long they if they were
made of what were made of Flesh they
wouldn't survive the trip so they would
have to send robots so maybe that's you
and the robots don't know their robots
so that's the right yeah that's going
back to Blade Runner yeah full circle
this is seeing you something
okay so while she's pulling this up
um or just putting that on prompter
um would you do a TV show for only fans
TV like me like produce one if I had a
good idea yeah yeah I guess I wouldn't
have to I wouldn't have sex though like
that would be the problem like yeah I
mean it could be some I know something
only for sexy challenging kind of
happening that could be fun what is the
key to the perfect blowjob
besides being you
um no teeth
um honestly I think I think there's a
lot of different things that can make a
good blowjob twisting
that's good yeah little little uh pepper
grinder using losing the mouth using a
lot of spit I would say um poking your
tongue out so that your tongue is coming
out I do that I wish I had a um
something I could demonstrate on I mean
you know what do you are you gonna could
this be mine could this be mine yes okay
favorite person it's easy at a deep
throat if you stick your tongue out so
don't keep your tongue in your mouth
right
the best day oh
all right so you're sticking I wish this
was more softer
um
so you can actually tickle the balls
with the tip of your tongue as well so
imagine these are the bowls right
whoa
right so you're using your tongue to
tickle the balls while the Dick's all
the way down your throat that is a game
changer
I'll I'll have a sip of this now
you made it come see it works every time
[Laughter]
every time
she just got a topo Chico sponsorship in
a a big way
um so something along the lines of
welcome to the only fans TV roast of
Whitney Cummings and your host for the
evening Hannah stocking what you're a
robot wild
for sure
[Laughter]
do you want to just do another one for
yeah was that too loud or was that good
or I mean do like three in a row okay I
always like to do like whenever I'm
doing something I'm like can I just do
three in a row so that you're not like
there's no pressure okay perfect
welcome to the only fans TV roast of
Whitney Cummings and your host for the
evening Hannah stocking
welcome to the only fans TV roast of
Whitney Cummings and your host for the
evening Hannah stocking Heaven perfect
that's it I feel like that last one
though I didn't give enough emphasis to
you I just it was like it was it was
calm but then you didn't get enough
attention I feel like I get enough
attention though like I feel like we'll
do one more I like I kind of like the
underplaying me a little bit because I
feel like such a narcissist it's just
like wait you know what I mean this is
about you but it is you have to accept
that this is your moment so your brain
welcome to the only fans TV roast of
Whitney Cummings and your host for the
evening Hannah stocking
you I deserve everything you have I love
it when I meet someone who is just
deserves everything they have and more
it's the best feeling it's only because
I have really big boobs and so I
couldn't play sports and so then I had
to take a different elective and that
elective was drama so I am a crazy
theater kid
you're but you just you're but you're so
clear you're not like hey
you're just like I'm gonna nail this and
you nail it thank you
literally I love to nail things real
things I'm sorry
I'm totally obsessed with you I love
hanging out with you thank you ditto
ditto Angela White there's I don't this
is the best day of my life I love you
guys thank you so much for coming don't
worry
[Music]
happened